[Music]
I think it's obviously important to have
ability and talent but I give more
weight to determination ambition and
Obsession in what you do
my name is Dr Wolf and I'm the CEO and
team principal of the Mercedes AMG
Patronus Formula One team
total wolf is one of the most successful
figures in auto racing but before he was
in auto racing he was an entrepreneur
when total wool founded March 15 he had
no money and ultimately his way of
building the business was he would go to
these small burgeoning internet
companies and basically say hey I'll
find you financing and exchange give me
equity
he did that with a number of companies
and scored some pretty big wins like SMS
provider UCP and game publisher Joe wood
after that he returned to his first love
racing and also he started managing
Junior drivers and this got him
connected with a company called hwaag
which was an engine provider for
Mercedes lower level racing teams and
eventually he got involved what 49 and
helped take them public in what ended up
being 175 million IPO
foreign
and raised in Vienna Austria and I
wanted to be a racing driver Formula One
race is all about Speed and Performance
and what I love in the sport is that the
stopwatch never lies you know
immediately where they've done a good
enough job and a lot of my most
important business lessons in racing
when I was competing at the age of 18
without having funds you need to raise
sponsorship and that was pretty
difficult so when I progressed into
Formula One as a team owner in Williams
I understood how important it was as a
private team to raise the necessary
funds to be competitive and eventually
win races
being a racing driver is also about
fitting in the car and since I've grown
very tall in my early 20s quite late it
wouldn't have been anywhere easy to race
in former one because the cars are so
small
[Music]
I became team principal of Mercedes with
the weird coincidence because I was a
co-owner of the Williams Formula One
team and it was going quite well we won
a race in 2012. top Management in
Mercedes asked me to assess why their
team wasn't going that well and I tried
to assess to the best of my ability and
they offered me the job and that was a
huge honor to run the Mercedes
Motorsport activities but I said to them
that I've always been an entrepreneur
and I have a stake in Williams
so they gave him an opportunity to
invest in the team that was originally
said to be 40 ultimately it ended up
being 30 and Nikki Lauda ended up
investing 10 as well and later on he
raised the state to 33 percent
[Music]
we've won eight consecutive
championships in Formula One but
probably the proudest moment that I had
was in 2014 when we finished first and
second and the other team Williams where
I was still a shareholder finished third
and fours and that was at the track
where I started racing with no money and
finding myself 25 years later winning
and and placing the cars in the top four
position was a super important moment
and made me really happy
I think if you work in Formula One you
need to cope with pressure and for me
personally it's almost like my comfort
zone I like the intensity of the race
weekend and of
whether it's Investment Banking or
resync it's highly competitive and
therefore you need to try to understand
as good as you can and then perform to
your best levels
foreign
wolf one of the first things that stands
out is how magnetic he is he seems to
command attention when he enters a room
and also he's extremely extremely
charismatic he's obsessed with
perfection and he's also really precise
which even spills over into his daily
life
I'm traveling to 24 races a year with
more than 500 hours of flying so I need
to stay disciplined in terms of sleep
nutrition and my life pattern so I'm
always eating the same things for
breakfast for lunch and in the evening
trying not to upset my system and
wherever I am I'm eating the same things
and for breakfast it's a pumpernick
bread two slices heavily toasted so it's
like a cracker butter a slice of ham and
a tomato on top and all of that with a
cappuccino and sparkling water
when he believes something he says it
and he's not afraid to own his failures
or you know take credit for his
successes
I think what made us successful over and
sustainably successful over the last 10
years was our culture and our values we
are brutally honest with each other
while still created a safe environment
where you can speak up where you can
point to inefficiencies and improve
it is all about integrity and honesty
and I'd rather give up a championship
than failing to these values
formula one has always been the largest
global sport that races every single
year real success for me is to have a
happy family have a great marriage and
three wonderful children and that is the
Cornerstone of me being so long
thereafter comes my professional life
and that is being successful with the
racing team winning world championships
and creating a structure and a team that
is sustainably successful
[Music]
laughs